okay what up guys welcome to the just
pearly things youtube channel um
morning coffee thoughts from my tesla
i know i have a quick coffee i know i
say this every time and i still don't
mean it i still don't mean it it
probably will never happen but you never
know um
okay today's morning coffee thought
is about
mindset and mentality and i want to talk
to you guys about how i got to where i'm
at um so
this whole social media journey started
when i was 22. okay
at 22 i was working a sales job and i i
freaking hated that sales job like
it was hell
i might have been 21 21 22. it was hell
on earth like i was selling copiers oh
my god i wanted to die
and
i remember like sitting in my bed and
thinking okay i want a family and i want
kids
but the stuff i want to do and i'm
passionate about is like a young
person's game and when i
i watched a jordan peterson video that
like talked about finding out what
you're passionate about and i wrote down
three things basically
um one was media and like music two was
people
and three
oh i had sports in there too so i guess
four things and four was like politics
current events like that that sort of
thing
and i realized that
oh you know i think i have music in
there but basically like the three
things that i broke down to was like
sports music
and
media were like the three things that
i'm really passionate about
and i couldn't sleep i remember lying in
bed thinking that i could not sleep
because
i only had so much time to do the things
i wanted to do
and i wasn't doing any of them and i
just like had this extreme anxiety so
what i decided to do
was i looked into playing overseas
and i when i decided when i go to
england to play volleyball
i am going to
focus on building a youtube channel
because i'm going to be at school again
so i'm going to have more time to like
build a channel and that's like what i'm
going to do when i'm there and so i
reached out to i decided to like start
networking okay and i decided i wanted
to talk to like more successful people
about their mindsets
so i
decided um i was in in sales so i had a
list of like companies and i was in
milwaukee at the time
and i decided to call executives using
that list i don't know if this is legal
but
sorry sorry if i'm admitting to
something um
but i i decided to call like in my own
personal time the list of contacts that
i had from the business and call
executives like at the sea level at
billion dollar companies and see if
they'd get coffee with me or meet with
me just to give like advice it wasn't
really necessarily i wanted to like be
the c-level executive of a billion
dollar company but i wanted to know like
what mindset got them there
and it was crazy because
me like taking that risk i got to meet
with two c-level executives from billion
dollar companies one was from harley
davidson one was from we energies and
they both like i got coffee with one and
i went to their office with the other
and i interviewed them on like success
and it was really interesting because
both of them talked about how to the key
to their success as people above all
else like it's all about people
relationships like that sort of thing
and i i just thought it was so
interesting and this was before i was
even in media like i didn't record it i
didn't i think i wrote like a
article about it that i didn't even post
anywhere
um
i just thought it was interesting so
then i decided
like
that i wanted to like network some more
so i ended up messaging the
director of media or no he wasn't the
director of media then he was like a
media manager at the daily wire and i
just asked him for career advice
so um
he
never got back to me okay so i messaged
him he said he'd meet with me and he
never did
a year goes by and in a year
i've started building my channel and i
remembered him and i was like oh let me
message him again and just see what he's
doing
he he ends up talking to me and agreeing
to manage my youtube channel so then i
get advice from someone
that knows way more than me about a
topic and guys you have to understand
when i meet these people i am asking so
many questions
i
i am always like if i find someone that
knows [ __ ] that i don't know like i just
want to know everything they know so
i'll ask them a million questions i
treat them like they're the most
important person in the room because
[ __ ] like they know more than i know
so
my point is
that
you can cut like like it's the mentality
that you can get in contact with anyone
and if you just try hard enough and
don't care what people think like you
can literally get a hold of anyone
i swear to god like one time i went door
to door looking for a job in rich
neighborhoods just because i wanted to
see
if i could get it like i just i just
wanted to see i got an interview request
and i didn't really want a job i just
had a youtube channel then but
from
like i i knocked on the door that was
like the ceo of a big company and i got
a call from a recruiter that week trying
to hire me like like this is just the
mentality you you never know
what you can do and this is the crazy
thing the bigger i get and the more
people that waste opportunities that i
give them is crazy
it is crazy to me because i know if i
was in their shoes and i had the
opportunity to be around someone and be
involved in a show
like that knows all that i know
and like i would be asking them so many
questions and people just don't they
don't take the opportunity in front of
them
and the crazy thing is i i've gotten
i have one friend i put on i got her
trending on twitter don't get me wrong
she was talented but that was an example
of somebody that took an opportunity
that i gave them that as soon as i i got
into contact with her like she's always
asking me questions she's always like on
the ball and like the thing is when you
are passionate about something and
people can feel that and people can feel
that you really want to be successful
people want to help you and they don't
want anything in return
and i tell this to my friend my friend
ally all the time when she's like why
are you helping me i'm like because
you're passionate you work hard and
honestly you're freaking talented i i
wouldn't
i wouldn't help you if you didn't have
those three things
and there's so many people i meet that
are honestly talented i think could make
it in the in media but they
they waste every opportunity i give them
and i give them so many opportunities
and it's it's just crazy because
i'm an expert at this stuff now i'm not
saying i'm huge
but if i was in their shoes and i got
to help out
and i got to like be a part of someone
something that had 70 000 subs and was
growing as fast as it was my channel is
like i would be all over it i'd be
asking a million questions the other day
there was someone that i met that was
behind the scenes had a lot of like
youtubers and
as soon as i met him and i realized who
he was i was i literally got this he was
trying to leave and i got this man to
stay like two hours because i was just
asking like a [ __ ] ton of questions
because that's just how i am
and there's so many people that
tell me they want to build a youtube
channel but they don't post anything
or
they
they tell me they want to build a
following and when i give them an
opportunity
to
build a following they they don't come
through like i'm telling you guys
i
if it was me and the other shoes i know
i would have moved i would have moved
mountains to figure out how to be
involved in this
but most people just don't want it that
bad
and people want to say oh you're held
back because of your race or because of
your gender or like as a woman i'm sorry
i've never been held back as a girl
i
i think it helps you because
people like pretty girls sorry
and
and it's it's frustrating because a lot
of the guys that are in this space and
talk about wanting to be like a high
value man and all that stuff like
they're not even willing to take the
risk to network
guys a network gets you so far i am so
much further because behind me i have a
manager that's really talented
and he he has taught me so much i am so
much further because behind me i
networked with donovan and donovan
helped me so much
like
people can give you shortcuts like if
someone talked to me i could tell them a
million things not to do that made my
life so much harder when i was building
my channel like it made it hell hell on
earth
and i i could tell you how not to do
those things but
the majority of people
don't want it and they don't they don't
want it that bad
because they don't take the steps in
order to get there
and
i
it is so satisfying
building something and being creative
and like making up something of your own
like three four months ago my show
didn't exist my reaction series didn't
exist where i i changed feminist's mind
like and that's something that i thought
of and that was creative and different
and
i mean don't get me wrong it's built off
of a lot of people's ideas like i credit
rollo and i credit a lot of people in
the space but
it is so cool to have something that i
built and was just in my head and now i
can see it like the the amount of like
satisfaction that you get out of that i
can't even describe
i
i would do this [ __ ] for free i i love
this stuff
and there's so many people that want to
be in media and want to do this [ __ ] but
they don't take steps to get there
they don't
they don't reach out to people that know
more than them
they're not willing to move for an
opportunity they're not willing to take
the risk
and
look stupid
online and and be bad at it guys you
will not build a channel
and be good at it if you look at my
first videos i have made three thousand
i i was looking the other day i i have
close to four thousand posts between
both of between tik tok and youtube some
of those posts were [ __ ] and honestly if
you guys find them they're probably
embarrassing please don't go back
because i'm too lazy to take them down
but
it's just part of the process like you
have to be bad at [ __ ] to get good
you will never be good at anything
if you're not willing to look bad and
look stupid and not care
i got made fun of so much when i was
coming up but look who's laughing now
anyways um i wouldn't even consider
myself a success story yet because i i'm
not there and clearly i have to keep
building and i'm still gonna be working
my ass off but
you can build anything
that you want
but sometimes it's about the connections
and the resources and you have to be
willing to jump through hoops to get
there so
okay be great build something cool
i love you guys and i'll talk to you
next time